the race to save Asian elephants has led
to some monkey business at the
Smithsonian's National Zoo in Washington
conservationists are trying to breed the
elephants there under human care fewer
than 50,000 of them are left in the wild
chip Reid is at the zoo with its big
idea chip good morning
well good morning there he is in all his
glory spike a 36 year old 7 ton Casanova
who was brought here to the National Zoo
for a very specific purpose
spike recently moved to Washington from
Florida and we were there as he was
released from quarantine so he could
meet three females he'd been admiring
from the other side of the fence there
was some trumpeting and some ear
flapping another sign of happiness but
with one Maharani Ronnie for short there
was some canoodling they do appear to be
hitting it off I'm no expert in elephant
love but that looks like something going
on there in fact this is not their first
meeting and as they say elephants never
forget spike and Ronnie were an item at
a zoo in Canada in 2014 Ronnie became
pregnant three times but sadly none of
the baby elephants lived past infancy
now the National Zoo hopes they'll have
better luck so so how is this going so
far going excellent
we really couldn't be happier these guys
have a great social history with one
another and we're hoping that they would
pick up where they left off and that in
fact seems to be what's happening we
returned yesterday and the good news got
even better Ronnie was ready to mate
earlier than expected it was like a
switch yesterday he was immediately
interested in folk laser focused on
Ronnie and she was also returning that
interest moreso than she had in the
previous days very glued to him and
solicit of him and that's continued
throughout the day today it's exactly
what they had hoped for
we brought spike here hoping that he and
Maharani would breed and produce
offspring so the first step we can check
off now they have bred
and will probably continue to throughout
the next day or so and then we'll have
to see what comes to that we'll test in
a few months to see if she's pregnant
and then begin planning in earnest for a
baby at that point if she is now they
they will use blood tests and ultrasound
to determine if Rani is pregnant but
another really good indicator of whether
she's pregnant is that spike will simply
lose interest in her by the way if she
does get pregnant you might want to
exercise some patience because a
pregnancy for an elephant lasts about 22
months Gayle
yeah that would be no fun good thing it
only happens to elephants thank you very
much chip you can tell that those two
have chemistry did you see the trunk
grab the tail that's the science that's
what boys do when they like you they
pull your hair oh dear yeah they do they
knew each other in Canada too it's got
like an elephant rom-com you know it's
gonna work out I have been to that
elephant Center at the National Zoo it's
it's all redone it is beautiful it's
really an incredible facility thank you
yeah thank you Jeff I like them